vinnie still wants to move into his  cousin's two-bedroom apartment that's  fully under construction  that i don't think will be ready anytime  soon  so i got him to compromise and come look  at apartments with me that i found  online  be careful i'm hoping that if baby and i  find a suitable place to live together  i'll feel better about my decision to  stay in ethiopia  it's big huh yeah it's actually pretty  big  yeah it's nice i like it oh  speak  oh my god we have hot water okay  i like it i like it  uh how much is it a month it's 45 000  a month 45 thousand  is the wi-fi connection strong of course  yeah  i like it i think it's much better than  everything else we've seen so far it's a  lot bigger  i mean you know you know that like has  very expensive like  i have a lot of jobs i'm working the  video charging  and then i'm working personal training  i'm working  circus in the night club and dance  [Music]  account  you